>>Winnie Lam: Hello everyone.
Iím Winnie Lam.
Thank you so much for attending this talk
about oceans.
We have two esteemed scientists here with
us from the Wildlife Conservation Society
whoís gonna tell us about our oceans.
Weíve got Claudio Campagna, Doctor Claudio
Campagna, and, um, Dr. Caleb McClennon both
from the Wildlife Conservation Society.
Dr. Claudio Campagna is the leading scientist
of the Wildlife Conservation Societyís Patagonian
Sea Program.
He specializes in the biology and conservation
of marine mammals.
In addition to having published five books
and 60 scientific papers, heís also been
the scientific advisor for the BBC and the
National Geographic Channel.
Heís gonna talk to us about our oceans.
And Dr. Caleb McClennon is the Marine Conservation
Director at the Wildlife Conservation Society.
He works on improving our fisheries management
globally so that we can conserve marine biodiversity
worldwide.
And for those of you who are here to hear
about the trip to Belize, heís gonna talk
to us about that.
So without further ado letís give a very
warm welcome to our guests, Dr. Claudio Campagna
and Dr. Caleb McClennon.
>>Caleb McClennon: Thank you, Winnie, and
thanks everyone for taking some time out of
your busy day to be here with us.
So, as Winnie mentioned, weíre gonna go through
a bit of some of the most fascinating places
in the worldís oceans today, some of the
challenges we face and then some stories of
hope that where weíre working and other people
are working to make a significant difference
in improving the health of the oceans.
And we wanna focus, specifically, on the Patagonian
Sea, a place where Claudio has spent close
to 30 years of his life working to help, to
help save and with remarkable progress and
I think really an inspiration to all of us
that we can make a big difference out there.
And then finally Iíll close with just a short
summary of this opportunity that we have to
host some volunteers in a Glover's Reef Research
Station in Belize and provide you a bit more
details about that opportunity and then weíll
have some time for questions.
So thank you all and itís really a pleasure
to be here at Google.
So, when we think about the oceans and what
drew you here or what inspires people to think
about caring about our seas.
Everyone has some sort of image like this
in their heads.
For me this is diving, actually at Glover's
Reef in Belize with two different species,
a Bottlenose and a Beak dolphin, swam side
by side next to me and just blow your mind
away in terms of taking you away from humanity
and bringing you into the sea.
So all of you probably, from some part of
your life, have your own image like this where
youíve connected individually on a personal
level with some species in the sea.
And if you havenít, it will happen and it
will really be fantastic.
So thereís these moments that are inspirational,
thereís also vast ocean ecosystems that have
tremendous biodiversity.
This is from Bunaken Reserve in the heart
of the coral triangle where you have 600 species
of coral reef, 3,000 species of reef fish.
For people who have been there and have seen
it, itís like no other place on the planet.
Itís the center, the center of origin for
marine biodiversity on the planet, a place
that is beyond comparison.
This is in the center of Indonesia in the
IndoPacific coral triangle.
So the oceans have this fantastic biodiversity,
this fantastic wildlife, these incredibly
important ecosystems but as we know, the oceans
are also critically important for the livelihoods
of tens of millions of people around the world.
They provide critical seafood for over a billion
people on the planet.
Ninety percent of fishermen living on the
planet are depending on oceans in small scale
aspects like these.
These are two fishermen off the coast of Madagascar,
living on one or two dollars a day, 100 percent
protein for their families is coming from
the sea.
So the sea is not just some fantastic aspect
of biodiversity for us to go to vacation to
and see, but is an elemental part of coastal
livelihoods throughout the world.
And this is really an important essence of
the oceans to also remember.
So when, on the other side of fishing from
the sea, thereís also as we know, and probably
people have heard far too much about, the
over-fishing crisis that we face on the planet.
We have trawlers, trawling in very close to
the shore line in places that have almost
no rules, taking in bycatch of marine turtles
and dolphins and over harvesting too many
species without any sort of regulations.
We are now importing far more seafood from
the developing world than we produce in the
developed world.
We are inadequately managing our fisheries
and taking them from places we have no idea
with the population structure, how much fish
we could possibly take out of the ocean.
So thereís a significant challenge that is
the industrial scale fisheries that are increasingly
moving into resource-poor and governance -poor
places.
An articulation of this is the crisis we face
with shark finning and shark fisheries today.
We woke up to the whales in the early part
of last century and we started an international
commitment to saving the great whales on this
planet.
As a result, around the world whale populations
are rebounding.
In 1970s, we woke up to sea turtles and as
a result many sea turtle populations around
the world are rebounding.
Today, weíre waking up to the shark finning
crisis.
WCS research that we had done in the last
decade indicates that between 40 and 70 million
sharks are taken, a year, from our oceans.
Almost none of the shark populations are assessed,
almost none of these fisheries are controlled.
This is a species crisis in the oceans of
our day.
As we, as was articulated two summers ago,
oil and gas extraction and is moving, has
moved into the Gulf of Mexico and is now moving
off shore to a number of countries around
the world.
This is a National Geographic map of oil infrastructure
in the Gulf moving out to about 150 miles.
This is physical infrastructure in the ocean.
When you look out in the ocean off the coast
of California, you see almost none of this
physical infrastructure because thereís moratorium
in oil drilling.
The Gulf of Mexico is a very different story
and the waters of a lot of countries around
the world is a very different story in terms
of oil exploration This is changing the way
we think of the oceans.
Weíre thinking about it as a space; a space
to be used and a space to be managed in a
way that we only thought of possible on land
before.
In some places, the rule of law for the oceans
is also incredibly challenging; such that
people are using dynamite still to fish or
to collect coastal aggregate materials for
construction.
This is a photo I took in the Marshall Islands,
where I lived for four years working for their
government, where theyíre still using reef
resources for mining materials because there
is no other resources for construction materials.
So the physical use of near shore reefs is
another significant challenge we face.
And then finally, as we all have heard from
many different angles, but we cannot mention
the oceans without describing the situation
of climate change and its impact to the oceans.
This is a reef in Aceh in Indonesia a year
ago prior to, a year and a half ago, prior
to the bleaching event that bleached out 100
percent of certain species of corals, in a
site where we worked.
So the white is what happens to corals when
all their symbiotic algae is expelled and
if the temperatures do not decrease after
a few weeks, the corals die, and thatís what
has happened in Indonesia.
It happened in a lot of places around the
world when temperatures were elevated.
So, like many ecosystems, the global impact
on climate change is also a considerable challenge.
This all being said, there is significant
hope in the oceans like there has not been
before.
There is a changing mindset in people and
in countries around the world to try to find
a way to better protect, better manage your
fisheries, expand protected areas out in the
oceans, ensure smart growth as opposed to
unregulated growth of extractive industries
and invest significantly more into scientific
research and understanding of the vast waters
of our planet.
Weíve invested a lot of money and time in
understanding domestic waters of the US.
And now a lot of that is changing to expand
throughout the world.
Just to point you out a bit of where we focus
is that thereís three centers of marine biodiversity
in the planet.
Basically the western edge of ocean basins,
so the western edge of the Atlantic is the
Caribbean, western edge of the Indian, the
western Indian Ocean and the western edge
of the Pacific Ocean, these are the hearts
of marine biodiversity.
Areas that are generally very nutrient poor
but have vast coral reef resources.
So these places are, in a planet that is covered
72 percent by ocean, some of the most critical
places to work to expand in protected areas
and improving fisheries.
There are also some places, again, along the
coast, where the greatest amount of productivity
is happening on the oceans, where 90 percent
of marine life is existing in the coastal
zone and you have huge aggregations of coastal
wildlife.
The Congo basin coast in Central Africa has
the worldís largest population of Leatherback
Sea Turtles.
For folks that have seen Leatherbacks, theyíre
talking 9 feet long, these creatures that
are extremely vulnerable, the last, the largest
population in the planet lives here and is
doing very well.
The Bay of Bengal has the worldís largest
population of Irrawaddy river dolphins and
coastal cetaceans
. But the government of Bangladesh, one of
the poorest countries on the planet, just
put in a protected area to protect a whole
slew of the population of river dolphins that
is bigger by a factor of ten than any other
population on the planet.
And in the Arctic, between Alaska and Russia,
which is experiencing incredible impacts from
climate change and receding of ice, there
was an effort to continue to protect walrus
populations, ice seals to manage through this
change and the indigenous communities that
actually depend on these resources to stay
alive.
And then finally the Patagonia Coast where
Claudio and a number of people who work for
him and partner with him are protecting the
largest continental population of Southern
elephant seals, penguins, albatross, in a
way, in protecting and restoring that abundance
in a way that is unprecedented around the
planet.
So there is incredible hope and incredible
demonstrated success of places where weíre
improving the health of the oceans and saving
a number of species and ecosystems.
Iím just gonna close with a few slides.
Some narrow slices of anecdotes that I think
are quite interesting.
These are several of our Indonesian staff
working together with some fisherman in Indonesia
that previously had used cyanide to fish for
the live reef fish trade; to take reef fish
out and bring them to restaurants still living
like we do with lobster.
And itís just a delicacy in East Asia.
We worked with them to halt the cyanide fishing
in exchange to pilot some agriculture programs
where they can more sustainably produce what
the market is demanding.
And as a result, they started managing their
fisheries better, thereís no more cyanide
on the reef and the biodiversity and the number
of fish is coming back out.
And theyíre economically doing better than
they were doing when they were using cyanide
in the reef.
So a win win, economically for these fishers
who are living on very few amounts of dollars
per day and also for the marine resource,
critical in a place like Indonesia where you
have 200 million people living in an island
country that is extremely small.
Thatís a photo from Belize.
These are Nassau Grouper which are critically
threatened throughout the Caribbean.
Most of the spawning aggregations of Nassau
Grouper have gone ecologically extinct in
the Caribbean because they come together to
breed, and thatís a very easy time to fish
them.
In Belize, the government of Belize over the
last thirty years protected all of the spawning
aggregations of Nassau Grouper and in some
places such as Glover's Reef, weíve quadrupled
the spawning populations of Nassau Grouper
as a result of protecting them where theyíre
spawning and also more smartly managing the
fisheries in the areas where weíre not able
to protect that species alone.
So a significant bounce back of a species
that we thought may go ecologically extinct
throughout the Caribbean because of the tremendous
value.
And this, again, is taken at Glover's Reef,
these are magnificent fish.
These are some guards working in Gabon in
Africa.
Thereís a country in Central Africa, as I
mentioned the worldís largest population
of Leatherback Sea Turtles.
The government of Gabon created, about 10
years ago created a significant network of
terrestrial protected areas to protect this
terrestrial biodiversity.
And just now theyíre committing, on the same
side, to create a large network of no-take
marine reserves in the waters, to protect
marine species, to protect fisheries and to
ensure larger protection for the overarching
marine ecosystem in a country in Central Africa
which is unprecedented for Africa, so incredible
hope for a place that has been generally under
prioritized.
And now we get to Claudio Campagna and some
of the work on the Southern Elephant Seal
and the Patagonia Sea.
I think a story youíll hear from Claudio
today in understanding these animals and the
understanding of what can be done to restore
oceans.
Not only in the US but around the world is
really impressive and needs to be replicated
in nearly every country.
And so I will leave it to him to tell that
story of success and continued possibility
for expansion of caring for and protecting
our oceans that is unprecedented.
>>Claudio Campagna: Well, that image actually
was helping me because this is being stretched
like that so the animal was looking a little
bit larger.
Yet, Elephant Seals are 5 meters long and
that was a particularly big one, so it was
helping me but in the right direction.
Iím going to talk about one place in the
ocean, the Southwest Atlantic of the way we
call it, Patagonian Sea.
You have to imagine an area the size of the
Mediterranean Sea, more or less, 1.5 million,
2 million square kilometers.
Most of these waters, the ones Iím specializing
in, are part of the economic exclusive zone
of Argentina.
However, these waters were very well known
in the 19th century because Darwin spent most
of the Voyage of the Beagle in that area;
a couple of years at least.
But today the Argentines, not necessarily
understand it.
Argentina is not a country that understands
ocean, oceans as much as it understands tango
and beef consumption.
[laughter] Thatís not a minor issue for someone
that wants to do ocean conservation that requires
people to understand what the ocean means
and to put value into that.
This is more or less the way the world sees
the ocean.
We just see the surface of the ocean.
We donít have a very good understanding of
what the ocean means.
And we see the ocean very close to the coast.
We understand the ocean up to here, basically.
And then we donít understand much more.
This is a kind of, I wonder, but this is a
kind of idea that I would suggest most people
have about the ocean.
Itís like a little bit of a combination of
reality and mythology.
Itís a surrealist perspective of the ocean.
And there are good reasons.
If you look at some of the ocean creatures,
they're very, very appropriate to create,
to promote our imagination about creatures
that do not exist.
Have a look at this Southern Right Whale or
at least South American sea lion.
These dolphins, mermaids, people were thinking
about these animals like that, or monsters,
it was not inappropriate, they were having
that understanding.
Just imagine ten thousand years ago, somebody
walking around the coast of Peninsula Valdez
in Argentina seeing these kinds of scenarios.
People were having that perspective about
the ocean.
The perspective that combines little bit of
imagination with a little bit of reality.
Then the scientists came and we changed that
perspective.
But we start to see the ocean in a very cold
way; satellite pictures of productivity; of
ocean temperature.
We were capable of understanding where most
ocean production was taking place.
But we started to lose sight of that mythology,
of that particular attachment that came from
the heart that caused fear but also caused
inspiration.
I think that the Conservation is trying to
bring together both worlds.
And this is what we have been trying to do
in Argentina.
My work there is on Elephant Seals, I work
on these big creatures.
What I do, what I started to do was to observe
the social behavior of these animals.
You have a Northern Elephant Seal very close
by.
I strongly suggest you have a look at that.
What we were doing most of the time is we
were sitting there on the beach watching the
behavior of these animals on the coast.
But then in the mid 1980s, the technology
was available to us, to understand what these
animals were doing when they were going to
the ocean, at sea.
Let me spend a second just to, okay, what
they were doing at sea.
One thing that we did immediately is to put
some recorders that were telling us about
the diving behavior of Elephant Seals.
And the people that were doing that work discovered
that Elephant Seals can dive up to a mile
under water.
And they can spend up to two hours without
coming back to the surface.
They are mammals; they have to come back to
the surface to get air.
And this was being discovered in the mid 1980s,
really.
With the Northern Elephant seal, he is very
close by research by AÒo Nuevo doing, working
on AÒo Nuevo from UC Santa Cruz.
At the time that was being done, technology
also allowed us to put instruments on Elephant
Seals that told us where the animals were
located in the ocean.
Iím talking the early 1990s.
And we discovered these animals were not find
food very close, like 5 kilometers, 10 kilometers,
100 kilometers, but very far away; 1,000 miles,
2,000 miles off the coast.
So all the sudden, we were facing a completely
new challenge.
For us protection, at the time, meant to do
something when the animals were on the coast,
to create protected areas to protect their
reproductive sites.
But Elephant Seals were spending 80 percent
of their time in the far away ocean, in the
open ocean, in the deep ocean, in the international
waters, places that were not protected at
all.
We scientists, devoted to conservation, do
worry about these things.
Cause we donít see the ocean like most people
do when they just approach the coast for a
vacation and they get all the beauty, we are
sensitive to that.
But, unfortunately, you have a special perspective
that looks at the ocean with the problems
that the ocean has.
So when Iím in Patagonia and I see a Magellanic
Penguin, of course I see the beauty of a Magellanic
Penguin, but I have seen also many, many oil
Magellanic Penguins so I want to do something.
When Iím working on Elephant Seals, of course
I love the social behavior they have when
they fight, they get very excited about that,
but then I see all the animals that are being
entangled because they get all these garbage
in the ocean, for some reason, they just swim
in and there are nets around their necks.
So, as conservationists, we have to face a
reality that many people donít want.
Is this what, I think thereís an expression
in English, this is a gloom and doom kind
of situation.
People say, ìOkay, we want to avoid that.
We want to avoid bad news.î Unfortunately,
we conservationists have to deal with that
because we want to solve those problems.
When we were learning what Elephant Seals
were doing in the ocean we conservationists
want to protect the areas where they are.
That means to protect the ocean.
Imagine that the coast of a national park
on land is already a very difficult concept.
If you want to create a national park in the
ocean, how do you start?
Particularly considering that most people
donít even understand the ocean beyond the
knee.
So we need to establish, itís a communication
problem, we need to establish that cause of
in the international community, in my case,
in the Argentine, and Southern Cone community.
And this is what we have been doing in the
last ten years and I will be telling you a
now, a little bit of a story about what the
achievements were.
First we started out, as I was telling you,
on coastal issues.
And we created a lot of coastal protected
areas.
A few years ago, the first coastal national
park was created in Argentina.
That was an achievement and that was a result
of long term research being done along the
entire coast of Argentina on many species.
Of publishing papers, publishing reports,
giving talks, talking to the Government, all
of that together resulted in the first coastal
national park of Argentina.
And thatís something to celebrate.
Another thing that happened very recently
is the creation of whatís called the Interjurisdictional
Park.
That is a park that belongs partially to the
province, the province of Chubut and partially
to the federal government, the national parks.
They got together, they speak to each other
and they decided to create a protected area
along the coast of Patagonia.
Thatís a very positive result, a very, very
encouraging result.
And protected areas like those, there are
many.
There are about 40 along the coast of Patagonia.
Some of them have been created in the 1980s
with the work of the pioneer people that went
there to explore.
Now weíre implementing more than exploring.
And itís happening, itís taking place, itís
taking momentum.
Itís a great time of history for that area
of the world, now, because many of the people
that weíre trying to study these animals;
Iíll go back to that.
Many people who are trying to study these
animals now have some power.
Let me illustrate very quickly what I have
said because perhaps you will get some better
idea, itís better to take home messages if
I go very, very quickly.
Yeah.
So I was here and I was saying, imagine youíre
walking here along the coast
>>Claudio Campagna: And all of a sudden you
see a killer whale stranded trying to get
sea lions.
Well, the other beauty is not just about individuals,
itís about colonies.
This is what you have in a temperate system,
lots of animals gathering together, very important
because they are very vulnerable, very beautiful.
Look at these black browed albatrosses.
They are reproducing in an island.
I mean, I just have so many things to say.
This is a colony of Elephant Seals, where
I work, that well, this is the way that scientists
are looking at these animals and these are
another way.
I wanna show you this, this is the distribution
of biodiversity, donít pay too much attention
to it, but whatís telling you is that you
donít find animals equally distributed in
the ocean.
There are some places that are really much
worse in terms of protection that require
much more work because, either there are many
more species or some species are so unique
that if you donít protect them they are not
being protected.
But this is the idea that I was telling you
that when how I feel when I do conservation
work.
I feel that there is some threat all the time.
When I see these animals, I think about that.
Itís not occurring at this place, itís not
taking place but it did occur in the past.
When I see these animals, I also see this.
This is still occurring today.
Okay, thatís the image of a conservationist.
We feel the weight of trying to support wildlife
and actually we are quite happy to do that.
One of the issues that we conservationists
in the ocean have to deal with is fisheries.
Look at this boat, this boat uses all that
light to fish squid.
Look at this image.
This is a photograph from a satellite.
Thereís more light there than in the city
Buenos Aires, almost.
And this is about a thousand miles long.
We're worried about these kind of issues;
entanglement, by catch, garbage in the ocean,
but we are many, trying to solve those problems.
And we are there in the field every day.
One thing that we do is science, satellite
tracking animals.
This is one thing that I satellite track,
look at that.
Left Peninsula Valdes went to the Malvinas-Falkland
Islands, round the Cape, into the South Pacific
open oceans to the Fjords of Chile and through
the Magellan Channel back to Peninsula Valdes.
This was a juvenile, those are the kinds of
challenges that we face if we want to protect
the ocean.
We have to come up with solutions to animals
that use the oceans like that.
And there are many.
There is not just the Elephant Seals, thereís
several species of penguins, turtles, etcetera.
Look at what the dimensions there are using
in the ocean.
There are over a million of square kilometers
thatís why we have to think like that.
Patagoniaís not just important because of
the resident species.
This is an albatross that is reproducing in
New Zealand.
After reproduction it crosses the Pacific,
spends some time along the coast of Chile
and then goes round to the Patagonian Sea
and spends the winter there and after that
goes round the world and back to the reproductive
area.
We put together, integrated all this information
into an atlas that is accessible in the internet.
Please have a look at this.
Itís www dot atlas dash marpatagonico dot
org.
Youíll see the distribution of 16 different
species.
And youíll find out how they compare to each
other and you can put maps there of productivity
to understand why theyíre distributed like
that.
I was telling you we have created protective
areas.
Let me give you an example.
The examples I was telling you, they are coastal
protected areas, but we are promoting open
ocean protected areas, this is the new concept.
Some of these open ocean protected areas do
not need to be protected all year around.
They could be temporarily protected when they
are very productive.
Others have to be protected in a way that
move around, are not stable, itís not like
the land.
In the ocean, things move so today youíre
protecting this but this is moving with the
current.
So in three months, youíre protecting this
area.
Those are the kinds of concepts that we are
trying to establish in the scientific community
but also among the stake holders that are
using those resources.
One of the very much open oceans, completely
open ocean protected area that was very recently
created is in this particular area called
the Burdwood Bank.
This is like an island under water and the
bottom of this bank is unique.
There are a lot of, what we call, endemic
species, species that you just find there.
And we protected a small portion of this,
but itís a beginning and itís very positive
one.
Iím not going to expect that you understand
this slide, of course, and itís not going
to look great in YouTube but there is one
issue that I think you will understand.
These are a group of fisheries called co-management
fisheries.
Thereís a paper published in Science or Nature
recently, itís Nature, they did an evaluation,
social scientists did, an evaluation about
what was important for these fisheries.
Why these fisheries were being successful.
What made them sustainable?
First variable that explained that is leadership.
The leaders of those communities were capable
of negotiating procedures, methodologies,
approaches that made those fisheries sustainable.
Very close to that is protected areas, protected
areas do work.
Of course, you need will in the community
and this is what thatís telling you.
So, in conservation like in your field.
leaders are critical.
Individuals make the difference.
And this is our leaders in the field in WCS,
particularly in Patagonia.
There are several and we have been working
there for almost half a century, 48 years,
since WCS started to have a project in Patagonia.
I think that I want to leave you with that
idea.
There is hope, we are achieving results, we
are facing huge problems but we feel that
communicating that will, we are going to convince
people that there is another way of looking
at the ocean that has not been the old one
with all the myths and itís not only the
ones that scientists use.
There is one that people want, that combines
knowledge with the heart, and this is what
we are trying to transmit.
Thank you very much and this is the webpage
I was telling you, please search it.
[Applause]
>> Caleb McClennon: So probably a number of
questions for Claudio that we asked to combine
it all then weíll have question, answers
about 5 minutes between the two of us.
So, obviously the creation, as you saw, there
are almost 50 reserves along the coast of
Argentina over those years is unprecedented
in the world and really congratulatory to
Claudio and his team.
Iím gonna speak briefly about this opportunity
that weíve put together and Winnie has really
been working with us to identify a way how
WCS, that works in 60 countries around the
world with thousands of staff in all these
different places could work with Google and
one idea that came up was we have a few permanent
research stations.
Research is really one component of conservation,
itís certainly not the entirety, but there
are some research stations that we have and
some of them are ongoing research projects
in places that weíve worked at 20 years or
so can use some assistance in terms of monitoring
because it takes a lot of people power as
well as thinking to monitor the state of the
ecosystem.
So this is an island in Belize which WCS has
owned for about 20 years.
We donít do a lot of land purchases in our
organization but this is on Glover's Reef
Atoll which is one of the only Atolls in the
Atlantic Ocean.
So a Coral Atoll is a ring island with no
center, the center has subsided away so itís
only coral growth keeping it above the sea.
In order to protect this place; which is one
of the most important places in the Caribbean;
which if you remember the beginning itís
one of the most important places in the entirety
of the Atlantic Ocean.
There needed to be a fisheries base there
for patrols.
And the fisheries department has to be actively
out there and regulating the fisheries.
As a result almost a third of the atoll is
fully protected and the rest is extremely
well managed fishery, uncommon for the rest
of the Mesoamerican Barrier Reef.
So the fishery department has a small base
here that they use, that they use for free
with us, and then we have our research station
where we have about twenty bunks.
And I guess part of this is to be very clear
what type of accommodations we have there,
basically twenty field bunks for staff, Iím
sorry for visiting scientists, student groups
and people that come through and assist us
with our research work.
So this is just a photo of the island and,
of course, we do a lot of work on all the
different aspects of the, a place we monitor
coral reef annually, spiny lobsters which
is the critical commercial fishery interest,
conch, different, several species of grouper,
we have a long term shark monitoring program,
interestingly the shark at Glover's Reef is
one of the only populations in the whole Mesoamerican
Barrier Reef that has been stable over the
last 20 years, whereas the rest of the areas
has started to go down.
So itís, with all this monitoring has shown
and been able to inform the success of our
work but also help us adaptively manage as
time goes on.
So in thinking through with Winnie as a way
we might be able to work together, we have
a sea turtle monitoring project that happens
annually, itís coordinated with the fisheries
department, all of work in Belize and in all
the countries where we work is done in coordination
with the management authority.
And so the end of April we will be going out
and require and need people to help us run
some transects and help monitor the entirety
of the atoll for its resident sea turtle population.
So it turns out that we came to Glovers Reef
for its robust biodiversity in terms of coral
reef and the fish populations were very healthy.
Some of our sea turtle researchers, similar
folks to Claudio, leaders in their field,
came in and did some work and identified that
this is a critical habitat for a lot of juvenile
turtles.
So for the last four years weíve been running
transects on an annual basis to identify and
start monitoring that population.
Certainly not for 25 years, the way Claudio
has with Elephant Seals in Argentina, but
weíre just starting to determine the relative
importance of the place.
So itís a great opportunity to participate
itís certainly not a vacation in that we
need the help and weíre not an ecotourism
outfit, weíre a research and conservation
organization.
So itís for anyone that is interested in
signing up or learning more about it, it is
absolutely going to be some work that youíll
be doing.
And we need to be clear about that otherwise
expectations will be very, very far.
What weíll be structuring the day like for
folks is half the day, we only have 8 slots,
so we only have the ability, though the station
can take more people, we can only actively
employ 8 people to be working on this and
we donít want to have a lot of people sitting
around.
So one half of the day will be participating
in the transect, the line monitoring for sea
turtles, the other half of the day will be
to recover or recoup, actually maybe enjoy
a little bit of the island.
And this is one island on the large atolls
so there is several actual tourism outfits
on the other parts of the island that we will
be able to find ways for people to have some
time off.
It will be 6 days that youíll be out here
on the island, then if you do decide to sign
up and have some interest in this and decide
you want to see more of the country of Belize,
cause thereís fantastic rain forest, jaguar
reserves, that would be on your own to stay
longer and arrange as well.
Our team, we have a boat, weíll take you
out to the atoll, so about 40 miles off the
coast of Belize and then weíll take you back
at the end as well.
So itís a really, we donít have a lot
>>Caleb McClennon: of opportunities like this,
weíre not an organization that is, this is
not part of our model of conservation, itís
just this happened, Winnie was great.
We threw around probably twenty different
ways we might be able to work together, this
talk today was one of them, and another was
this trip which Winnie has been fantastic
about trying to find a way for us to work
together.
So, happy to answer questions about that,
questions about what you might see in Belize
and then Claudio is here all the way from
Argentina as well, so I hope there might be
a few questions about the fantastic work that
theyíve been doing there.
Thank you very much for your time, itís been
really great to have this opportunity, we
really appreciate it.
[Applause]
>>Caleb McClennon: So if you have questions
if you donít mind using the microphone so
people could hear you or you could, I guess,
decide you donít want to be on the microphone.
[Laughs]
>>Caleb McClennon: Yes.
>>Female #1: I just want to, yeah so you guys
can hear me, exactly what kind of work [inaudible]
>>Caleb McClennon: So the timing youíll be
spending, because youíll be split into groups
of four, so the time youíll be spending on
[inaudible], youíll be out on a boat and
swimming, so snorkeling, not scuba diving,
that would bring in a whole other set of complications,
snorkeling and we do linear transects swimming
for identifying any of the sea turtle groups,
uh, species that are there.
So we have greens and hawksbill and sometimes
several other species that come through.
But greens and hawksbill are the primary.
Um, so itíd be about, uh, from when you leave
the dock, our pier here, thereíd be about
4 hours out to the survey site that we choose
for that day, cause itís a random selection
of sites throughout the Atoll; thereís some
statistical, no thereís very much statistical
significance because itís been designed by
our ecologists.
Then youíll be swimming transects for several
hours, moving around a few times, we do catch
the turtles.
Youíre not required, because it is a physically
difficult thing to catch the turtles, but
we do catch them and if you do we will tag
them and we will have several, one if not
two, satellite tags that weíre hoping to
put on if we get the appropriately aged turtle,
so afterwards you build a follow.
Thereís a website called seaturtle dot org
which freely allows you to monitor turtles.
So hopefully if things all go well and weíll
have one we can tag with a satellite receiver
and be able to track after the trip.
Then youíll come home.
So youíll just have had breakfast, be out
for up to 4 hours, come home for lunch and
then the afternoon would be yours.
There is, not extremely high speed Wi-Fi,
but there is some Wi-Fi.
I wouldnít expect anyone that does a lot
of modeling or anything like that would be
able to do that through the internet, but
you would have some communication.
And that part of the day would be a bit of
a break.
Weíve got a great Belizean, our whole team
that youíre gonna be working with is a Belizean
team.
Our team leader, Robin Coleman is a PhD ecologist
from Belize and a champion for conservation
there.
And a whole set of the Belizean fishery staff
will be with you and we have about five permanent
staff at this station who will be serving
you food, maybe as good as we ate today at
Google, I donít know, those of you that go
can tell us, but great solid Belizean food
to make sure that you donít waste away when
youíre out there.
Does that help?
>>Female #1: Yes.
>> Caleb McClennon: Okay.
Yeah?
>>Male #1: So you mentioned that Argentina
is more about salsa and beef than oceans.
[Laughter]
>>Claudio Campagna: Tango.
Tango.
>>Male #1: Oh right
>>Claudio Campagna: Yeah.
>>Male #1: Um but that this new reserve had
been created, in the Southern part of the
ocean, does that, do you perceive that thereís
a sea change going on that the people, the
leadership are bringing more there and accelerating?
>>Claudio Campagna: Yes.
Very much, the head of the National Parks
of Argentina today, Patricia Gandini is a
person that understands the ocean.
She has been working with WCS for a long time,
she has a PhD, do work on penguins and she
has been facilitating the process of creating,
not just national parks, but many interjurisdictional
areas and I think that makes a difference.
Leadership, again, she understands that.
Patriciaís boss, actually, is a minister
of the tourism in Argentina and he understands
protected areas, very, very much.
And I think that we have some political will
there that is aligned and is very important.
Peninsula Valdes, which is one of the most
beautiful places on the coast of Patagonia,
the person in charge of Peninsula Valdes,
[unclear] who is a secretary of tourism, is
a conservationist and is part of an NGO that
I help create with her and other WCS people.
So things are happening because the Indonesians,
now, are in the right positions to make things
happen and the Argentines are very sensitive.
If, the sooner they are being informed about
an issue they respond.
They donít want the penguins to be killed;
they donít want the penguins to be oil they
worry.
So I think itís a community that historically
has not been very much trained to watch the
ocean but is very easily trained.
>>Male #1: One more question.
This is kind of a softball but what, beyond
coming and counting turtles, what can we as
people who care about the ocean, do to affect
change around the world and save the biodiversity
of the oceans.
>>Claudio Campagna: You can help the NGOs
that are doing ocean conservation, no, this
is more than that, itís much more.
There are many, many things that you can do.
First, youíre a consumer of ocean products,
even if you donít want; you are, in some
ways or another.
Be a responsible consumer.
Be aware that many fisheries are not sustainable
and that many species should not be consumed.
Itís very easy to find Chilean sea bass here
and you have to be aware of that.
Itís very easy to find shrimp in any cocktail,
you should be careful about that because shrimp
causes a very high bycatch.
In some places of the world, one pound of
shrimp, one kilo of shrimp results in ten
kilo of diversity that is being thrown away
because it has no commercial value.
So as a consumer you could really, really
do a lot.
You can also spread the word.
You have seen the finning problem, shark problem.
The world does not necessarily know much about
that.
Youíre educated people, you know that, but
many people donít.
Be sure that you talk you integrate conservation
in your everyday discourse.
Youíre, you know, as Caleb was saying today
[inaudible], itís a castle of; itís an intellectual
paradise that would, that is a communication
paradise.
Make sure that the world knows that there
is an ocean there and that the ocean requires
our support.
Many people of the world believe that the
ocean is an exhaustible, I mean, cannot be
used up, thatís a wrong perception, we need
to change that.
You could help develop technological tools.
For example, to map areas or to create, to
analyze, to do spatial analysis, zoning, so
you can contribute with the technical aspects
of it.
You can educate your children, your friends;
thatís extremely important.
You could be part of some of our expeditions
and some of our work.
Get involved in really obtaining the information.
>>Caleb McClennon: I should add that on Google
ocean layers, that Google has supported, Claudioís
site is one of the first participants in providing
>>Claudio Campagna: Yeah.
>> Caleb McClennon: So there has been ways
that weíve worked together as well.
>>Claudio Campagna: So and today I was just
coming and all of a sudden we say [inaudible].
So the community of Google is sensitive to
the ocean.
I was very gladly surprised.
And of course Google brain could change the
world in the way we see the ocean.
>>Caleb McClennon: Any other questions?
Yeah?
Stay here.
>>Claudio Campagna: Oh.
>>Male #2: I was wondering how you decided
when, how much of your effort to put on protecting
the deep sea versus the coastline?
>>Claudio Campagna: Most of my life I dedicated
to doing work that was helpful for coastal
protection, thatís what I did.
And today the WCS in Argentina is still doing
that and in the Southern Cone because we also
work in Chile very much.
You know, there are some areas of Chile that
are extraordinary as coastal areas.
The Fjords of Chile are unique.
You donít find those places in any other
place in the world.
So many, many people, most people, most of
the effort that we put there is about coastal
conservation still today.
It is required.
A proportion of us have the courage to move
away from that specific need into another
perspective for which we did not have a big
market.
People were understanding that the coasts
had to be protected because you see the coast.
You donít see the ocean and you donít see
the depth, the deep ocean.
I have been leading what is called a Sea and
Sky Project, the name is suggesting that the
way I think about the ocean and the sky, I
do think about the coast, of course, but Iím
trying to promote these ideas of the deep
ocean protection, around the ocean protection.
For me itís most of the work that I do.
For the organization, itís a proportion of
that work that we what we do.
The open ocean has many problems as you might
know, one is jurisdictional.
Countries have a decision on the first two
hundred miles and there they could determine
whoís coming whoís leaving what is being
done.
Beyond the two hundred miles itís the commons,
itís everybody owns it.
There are some laws but it is very difficult
to enforce whatís going on.
And fisheries today are moving into that realm.
Theyíre moving into international waters.
There are a group of people, and we are part
of that, alliances of organization that are
trying, organizations, that are trying to
understand what can be done to protect the
international waters.
And a few things are being done and a few
places must be protected.
For example, sea mounds.
The sea mounds are very, are places deep in
the ocean that are unique because you have
a flat ocean and all of a sudden you have
something like that.
And that creates particular very sensitive
places where you have a biodiversity that
is only there.
Those sea mounds are being fished.
So we need to protect them and there is a
strong effort into trying to do that because
we donít even know the species that are there.
So, as an answer is, most of the work still
requires to be done on the coast.
Thatís a must, but a few of us itís sustainable
if a portion of us will move into the more
challenging, more experimental phases.
But those experimental phases have to be turned
into, not that experimental, but into something
more tangible very soon otherwise itís very
easy to destroy this small environment like
a sea mound.
>>Claudio Campagna: Did that, does it answer?
>>Male #2: Yes.
>>Caleb McClennon: Okay, any other questions?
Yeah, go ahead.
>>Male #3: Uh, Claudio a question.
>>Claudio Campagna: Yeah.
>>Male #3: Is the trip restricted to Google
employees or what about qualified friends?
>>Caleb McClennon: For the moment, uh, if
you sign up itís restricted to Google employees
just cause currently, from what Iím understanding
of demand, we have more than 8 from Google
so we like to keep it that way.
But if you are signing up and would like to
make a note that if it doesnít fill up weíd
like to bring someone as well we can open
up that question if itís possible.
>> Female: [Inaudible]
>>Caleb McClennon: Sheís the boss so yes,
there you go.
[Laughs]
>>Caleb McClennon: I should say, cause I notice
a couple people are leaving, we had you stay
til the end of the hour for questions but
if itís not apparent, I think it will be
apparent that if youíd like to sign up please
go to that address and I think on this email
for the work, for the talk today , you saw
thereís an address to sign up and weíre
taking applications or your expressions of
interest until Monday and then weíre gonna
make decisions cause I know people will need
to plan their personal lives cause itís the
last week in April.
So if youíre interested, please before, on
the Glover's Reef trip, please sign up and
put all of your information in to that address
by Monday.
We have a couple more minutes for, uh, if
thereís anything Iím missing just from folks?
Okay.
We have two more minutes for people and then
weíll take casual questions after.
>>Claudio Campagna: Let me just say one thing
more about your question about what you can
do.
Letís be in touch, letís talk because thereís
some things that people have to understand
about what they want to do.
>>Caleb McClennon: Yeah.
>>Claudio Campagna: And we can help guide
that.
So I just gave you a general understanding
but, you know, if you want to talk about that
Iím very open to discuss it with you and
everybody.
>>Male #4: Is the political tension between
the Argentina and the Falkland Islands proving
to be challenging or do people find ways to
work around.
>>Claudio Campagna: Yes.
It is.
The war between the UK and Argentina in 1982
was unfortunate.
It is a problem that you can analyze from
many different perspectives.
Certainly the political perspective is not
my place to analyze that problem.
I could speak as an individual but from a
conservation perspective it is a pity that
that happened cause now all of a sudden one
ocean is being seen from many different perspectives
and that does not help.
Cause the ocean does not work like that.
So countries have to make decisions on a regional
level and a very large level.
That problem is creating some issues some
dialogue has been interrupted.
And now there are some developments that are
taking place in the Islands that Argentines
donít decide about and thatís causing clearly
tension.
I had the hope, I mean I have it, that perhaps
the conservation perspective has an umbrella
that embraces that problem and puts that into
perspective.
But it has to, we need time.
And yes, it has been a problem.
And for us has been a challenge to think in
the open ocean considering that situation,
that jurisdictional issue.
>>Caleb McClennon: Alright.
Well, thank you so much everyone.
Thanks to Winnie for being our host, we really
appreciate and look forward to talking to
you each individually or afterwards.
And thank you from WCS to Google and look
forward to working together.
[Applause]